[Musique]
au salon de l'agriculture 2010 9
dégustation de produits du terroir
français
découvertes gustatives visite
incontournable des animaux et petit
bisou pour certains je compte devenir
agriculteur dans quelques mois
et ça me semblait intéressant une c'est
une opportunité pour moi de venir de
voir un peu autre chose
et parmi tous les stands du salon
bientôt du vin 100% yvelinois en 2017 la
winery parisienne a planté ses premiers
pieds de vigne à d'avron elle veut
réinventer la filière viticole en ile de
france vivait pour nous était de
reproduire des vins dans la plus grande
d'anciennes plus grandes régions
viticoles de france et l'île de france
pour produire des grands vins dans la
région sur la plaine de versailles la
première cuvée est annoncée pour 2020
côté assiette la ferme d alu et propose
des légumes anciens et nouveaux
sur les étalages topinambours radis noir
route à bagua j'ai une cinquantaine
d'hectares
en fruits et légumes que je revends sur
les marchés en ile de france car entre
aux choux de bruxelles rouge novembre
vraiment des légumes qui sortent de
l'ordinaire
le département des yvelines est le
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france
il participe au salon pour la deuxième
fois avec les hauts-de-seine
ils sont complémentaires parce que
l'agriculture c'est une production et
une consommation
et si les yvelines sont un département
producteur ce que les hauts-de-seine ne
sont pas les hauts-de-seine comme les
yvelines d'ailleurs sont des
départements pour ce batteur et en
particulier consommateurs dans nos
cantines scolaires de nos collèges les
yvelines favorisent les produits locaux
et intègre les produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique au concours
général agricole
y a eu la médaille d'argent sur un
yaourt à l'abricot destinés à la
restauration collective pour les enfants
des écoles du département
notre gamme
on doit envoyer à vous faites 30 à 40000
euros par mois qui sont dédiés
cantine hôpitaux le territoire des
yvelines est composé de 90 mille
hectares d'espacés agricoles
avec près de 1000 exploitations
l'agriculture c'est un marqueur fort des
yvelines aider à l'installation et au
renouvellement des générations
il faut installer des jeunes
agriculteurs des jeunes agricultrices et
donc on y travaille en les aidant
financièrement on les aide aussi à se
transformer au niveau écologique
énergétique
vous pouvez encore faire un tour le
salon de l'agriculture se termine ce
dimanche 3 mars
[Musique]